>>> AS THE GABBY PETITO HOMICIDE
CASE GARNERS NATIONAL ATTENTION,
ANOTHER YOUNG PERSON HAS BEEN
MISSING NEARLY THREE MONTHS, AND
HIS FAMILY IS DESPERATE TO FIND
HIM.
24-YEAR-OLD DANIEL ROBINSON WAS
LAST SEEN JANUARY 23rd LEAVING
BUCKEYE, ARIZONA.
HIS JEEP WAS FOUND IN A RAVINE
FOUR MILES FROM WHERE HE WAS
LAST SEEN.
THE VEHICLE APPEARED TO HAVE
ROLLED AND LANDED ON ITS SIDE.
DANIEL'S CLOTHES, CELL PHONE,
WALLET, KEYS, WERE ALL FOUND AT
THE KEEP.
POLICE SAY FOUL PLAY IS NOT
SUSPECTED.
BUT DANIEL'S FAMILY SAYS
OTHERWISE.
JOINING US IS HIS FAMILY.
WE HAVE DANIEL'S FATHER, DAVID
ROBINSON, AND HIS BROTHER ROGER
CAULEY ROBINSON.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON TO TALK
ABOUT DANIEL.
I WANT TO START FIRST, DAVID,
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR SON.
>> THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US ON,
BRIANNA.
DANIEL, HE'S A VERY OUTSPOKEN
GUY.
FROM HIS CHILDHOOD.
DANIEL, HE'S ALWAYS CHALLENGED
EVERYTHING.
HE CHALLENGED HIS SIBLINGS.
HE WANTED TO OUTDO THEM
ACADEMICALLY.
EVERYONE KNOWS HE WAS BORN
WITHOUT A RIGHT HAND.
HE NEVER LET ANYTHING STOP HIM.
HE LEARNED HOW TO PLAY THE
FRENCH HORN, TROMBONE.
WHEN HE GOT INTO COLLEGE, HE
SOUGHT OUT TO BE A GEOLOGIST.
HE PURSUED HIS DREAMS AND
ACCOMPLISHED THOSE GOALS,
GRADUATED WITH HONORS.
HE ALSO IS A FRIENDLY GUY.
HE ALWAYS HAD FRIENDS.
AT COLLEGE, I HAVE SEEN SO MANY
OF HIS FRIENDS THAT LOVED HIM.
DANIEL IS A GUY WHO LOVED TO
TRAVEL.
HE SPENT TIME WITH A FRIEND
TRAVELING.
HE LOVES NATURE.
HE LIKED TO DO HIKING.
ONCE HE GOT OUT HERE TO PHOENIX,
HE LIKED TO HIKE, TRAVEL, LIKE I
SAY, SEE NATURE.
AND HE LOVED HIS CAREER AS A
GEOLOGIST.
HE HAS A ROCK COLLECTION.
HE LIKED TO COLLECT ROCKS.
BUT HE'S A PERSON THAT LIKED TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
EVEN IN THIS MOMENT WHERE HE IS
NOT HERE WITH US, HE IS BRINGING
EVERYONE TOGETHER RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF PERSON DANIEL
IS.
>> I WILL TELL YOU I HAVE BEEN
READING ABOUT YOUR SON, AND I
HAVE BEEN SO IMPRESSED BY LIMB
AND WHAT A SPECIAL PERSON HE
CLEARLY IS.
YOUR BABY BROTHER, ROGER.
>> YES.
.
>> RIGHT NOW AUTHORITIES ARE
SAYING THAT THERE IS NO FOUL
PLAY SUSPECTED.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOUR FAMILY
THINKS.
TELL US ABOUT THIS.
>> WELL, THERE'S TOO MANY THINGS
THAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS CASE.
FROM THE BEGINNING, YOU KNOW, --
YOU KNOW, FROM A FAMILY
STANDPOINT, DANIEL, HE WOULD
NEVER DO ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF
TELLING HIS FAMILY.
THE FIRST INDICATION I THOUGHT
THAT WAS VERY STRANGE WITH
DANIEL IS AFTER SIX HOURS, NOT
HEARING FROM HIM AT ALL, HE
DIDN'T CALL HIS SIBLINGS, HIS
MOM OR MYSELF TO LET SOMEBODY
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
BUT ONCE DANIEL BECAME MISSING,
WE REALIZED THAT I THINK THE
QUICK ACTION WASN'T THERE QUICK
ENOUGH, FIRST OF ALL.
THAT CAUSED ME TO HAVE TO DO MY
OWN SEARCHING AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
BUT ONCE HIS VEHICLE WAS FOUND
AND THE WAY IT WAS FOUND, IT
JUST DIDN'T LOOK RIGHT.
IT DIDN'T SET RIGHT WITH ME.
I GOT MY OWN PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR FROM THAT POINT.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS FOUND FROM
THAT POINT INDICATES THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO LOOK A LITTLE
FARTHER THAN SAYING HE IS JUST
MISSING.
>> ROGER, THE BUCKEYE POLICE SAY
THAT THE CASE REMAINS OPEN AND
ACTIVE.
THEY SAY CURRENTLY WE ARE
CONSULTING OUTSIDE EXPERTS FOR
ENHANCED ANALYSIS OF THE DATA
FROM DANIEL'S VEHICLE.
WE ARE ALSO ASKING ANYONE WITH
INFORMATION TO PLEASE CONTACT
INVESTIGATORS.
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU THINK,
ROGER, ABOUT WHAT POLICE ARE
DOING AND WHERE THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO YOUR
BROTHER'S DISAPPEARANCE, WHERE
IT STANDS?
>> FROM WHAT I'M GETTING FROM
THIS, I FEEL THAT, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT AT THIS POINT.
BUT I FEEL IT'S A LITTLE TOO
LATE.
LIKE MY FATHER SAID, HAD THEY
BEEN QUICK ABOUT IT IN THE
BEGINNING, WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
THREE MONTHS LATER STILL
SEARCHING FOR MY BROTHER, STILL
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS.
I THINK MY SISTER THAT LIVES IN
ARIZONA AND MY FATHER DID A LOT
IN THE BEGINNING TRYING TO PUSH
AND GET THINGS MOVING, PLEADING
WITH THE POLICE, YOU KNOW,
BEGGING FOR THEM, HEY, CAN YOU
HELP GET A SEARCH, CAN WE DO AN
AIR SEARCH, SOMETHING.
AND I THINK THE LACK OF ACTION
IS LEADING US HERE.
NOW THEY ARE HAVING TO BACKTRACK
AND TRY TO BRING OUTSIDE SOURCES
TO HELP SEARCH FOR MY BROTHER.
>> YOU KNOW, ROGER, I WONDER
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THERE IS
NOW ATTENTION.
THERE IS SOME NATIONAL ATTENTION
ON YOUR BROTHER.
THAT SO INFREQUENTLY HAPPENS IN
THE CASE OF A YOUNG MISSING
BLACK MAN OR A YOUNG MISSING
WHITE WOMAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT AND
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN?
>> I THINK THAT IT'S SAD THAT WE
STILL HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, THINK
IN THAT WAY.
I WILL SAY MY PARENTS NEVER
RAISED ME AND MY SIBLINGS TO
BELIEVE THE WORLD IS OUT TO GET
US.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE SOME VERY
OBVIOUS THINGS THAT HAPPENED
HISTORICALLY AND THINGS THAT
STILL HAPPEN TODAY THAT'S NOT
VERY GREAT IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT JUST SADDENS ME THAT IT
TAKES THIS MUCH, YOU KNOW, TO
GET PEOPLE'S STORY OUT LIKE MY
BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FEND ON
OTHER STORIES OR OTHER CASES TO
PUSH OUR OWN STORY.
AND WE JUST WANT ANSWERS JUST
LIKE ANYONE ELSE.
I THINK MY BROTHER OR EVERYONE
ELSE'S BROTHER OR FATHER,
SIBLINGS, WHOEVER THEY MAY BE,
THEY DESERVE THE SAME ATTENTION.
>> DANIEL IS A VERY SPECIAL
PERSON.
WE HOPE SOME MORE EYEBALLS ON
THIS CASE MIGHT GET SOME MOR